today is Monday January thirteenth and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
waters filling in for Jess McDonald for
just a few days I don't know exactly why
but I do know a few new stories that i
can tell you maybe make few jokes so
let's do that last week's cries of
lamentation and rending of clothes over
titanfall matches being limited to 6v6
have elicited a response from developer
respawn entertainment to those who voice
their concerns that matches would be too
small producer dhruva coy posed the
question what about hi player counts
makes that more fun though I honestly
want to know because this kind of stuff
is super important and we obsess over it
every day if having more people is just
core to what you expect for fun then I
guess that's it McCoy said that said
this is a multiplayer game and we do
plan on supporting it adding to it and
making it better player feedback is
something we crave and want to do things
based on personally I think the idea
that having more players in a match
makes it inherently better is absurd two
versus two or 64 verse 64 it's all down
in the game design and how well it comes
together so there's that for you
speaking of player feedback after ten
months of online only urban development
SimCity will finally allow players to
play the game offline in a post on the
SimCity blog Maxis general manager
Patrick buechner wrote in update 10 you
can still play solo in regions on your
own or in multiplayer with people from
around the world what's new is single
player mode which allows you to play the
game offline by yourself and because
your saved games in this mode are stored
locally you can save and load to your
heart's content he also mentioned that
offline mode provides a great
opportunity for modders to put their
stamp on SimCity personally I'm hoping
to be able to recreate hobbiton and all
its pastoral glory though I'm a little
worried about the waste management
problems facing a population that eats
four meals before noon
the xbox one won't be Microsoft's last
hardware-based console according to a
tweet by xbox executive Phil Spencer I
think local compute will be important
for a long time he said you can look at
mobile connected to faster networks more
cloud services but local power still
increases each gen though Microsoft does
see an all-digital future for gaming
Spencer cited bandwidth caps as one of
the many issues yet to be overcome on
the road to a less cluttered living room
as for the current landscape of gaming
sony has spoken out about how tablets
and smartphones have hindered sales of
the PlayStation Vita speaking to VG 24-7
Sony UK managing director Fergal gara
said the market Vita entered was more
complicated than it was when the console
was originally thought about and design
games on tablets and phones have changed
the marketplace and people can't carry
too many things around at one time the
truth is that the number of people that
want the core experience is not as big
as the number that simply want any sort
of game available on the move so what do
you folks think have you bought a Vita
are you planning to do you even want one
I mean come on you can play spelunky on
it all right that's about it for me just
one more tidbit hear the petition to
bring GTA 5 to pc has surpassed six
hundred and fifty thousand signatures
love the enthusiasm it's probably going
to happen but don't quote me on that or
take my word for it or believe anything
that I say share your thoughts on
today's stories on the world wide web
using twitter and hashtag GS news or
comment below thanks for watching and
I'll see you tomorrow